[Applause]
please welcome mark cuban
oh
at times we have learned all of us are a
little too intimidated to go up to
someone i saw you in a restaurant one
time eating
i didn't want to bother you oh it breaks
my heart i'm such a huge fan i'm such a
fan of viewers i'm above a bigger fan
well maybe as a neon sign says in my
entryway that i hand wrote and turned
into a neon sign timing is everything
okay well here we are
thank you i'm so glad to make i am so
glad to be here okay so i have to leap
right in and ask you about the
prescription drug program that you have
started yeah
costplusdrugs.com
tell us about it thanks for bringing up
i mean so like all of us we've looked at
the price of medications and they just
keep on going up and so about three and
a half years ago i started working with
dr alex oshmanski and so with the way
prescription drug pricing works right
now is there these things called
pharmacy benefit managers that act as a
middleman and they distort all the
pricing and so we said we'll become a
pharmacy benefit manager but we're not
we're going to take out all the price
distortions so as a result if you go to
costplusdrugs.com we have about 110
drugs that we sell now that'll go up to
2000 by year-end and when you add it all
up some of our prices are 90 95 lower
than traditional drug pricing
this is literally why i'm so enamored
with you i mean
i found out an interesting fact uh doing
research on you you purchased a small
town
in texas yeah mustang texas
why did you buy the town okay so i'm
gonna sound corny again but um
one of my buddies i've been a basketball
junk in my entire life so i go play
pickup basketball one of my buddies that
i played pick up basketball with um
cancer
and um was close to dying and his only
real asset was this town mustang texas
and i'm like well i can help marty and i
could buy this town and so i bought the
town and so i mean it was a cool concept
right it was like
it's the only town in all of the state
of texas that
is available for sale and so i bought it
and what we do with it ties back to
shark tank maybe we're trying to decide
so there's a guy on shark tank dino dan
or dino don and he he makes the
animatronic dinosaurs like if you go to
zoos and everything and you see these
huge animatronic dinosaurs that look and
sound real and we did a shark tank
episode on it and i invested in them so
we haven't worked it through yet but
there's a chance we might change mustang
texas to dinosaur texas and do one just
having all these big huge jurassic park
like dinosaurs so okay you have a small
town now are you the mayor are you the
sheriff no i i got one of my buddies
you wear a star
what what happens when you purchase a
small town how are you then responsible
for it um i made one of my buddies the
mayor which basically means he's
responsible for cleaning the trash and
keeping it clean that's the job of the
mayor of mustang texas that's why we
might change it to dinosaur texas but
that's a long shot
[Music]
you